Hi, I'm Mike from the
YouTube desktop team,
and I'm going to
talk about how WebP
helps to make YouTube faster.
You may not realize
it, but YouTube
is one of the largest image
hosting websites serving
tens of billions of video
thumbnails every day.
On many pages of
YouTube, thumbnails
can contribute up to
80% of total size.
In fact, a typical
page can easily
contain more than a
megabyte of image data.
All those thumbnails add up.
Client side techniques
like lazy image loading
helps us to optimize
rendering time,
save bandwidth, and mitigate
extensive vacant lot,
but until recently,
we had no way
to significantly optimize
the images by themselves.
Fortunately for us, it turns out
that's another team at Google
has been working on the
WebP image format that
delivers a significant
improvement in image size
up to 30% while maintaining
the same quality.
So we decided to give it a try.
By the time WebP wasn't a
complete stranger to us,
as we already used it
for image supplies,
but all the data we
had was relevant only
to lossless compression.
So earlier this year,
we ran an experiment
to encode a fraction
of video thumbnails
hosted at YouTube
in lossless WebP,
we aimed to measure
the bandwidth savings
and confirm that
WebP helps improve
rendering time of web pages.
Knowing about the
benefits of WebP,
we still had to consider that
introducing a new image format
is not free.
At a minimum, it
meant that we had
to store multiple
variants of the thumbnail,
WebP versions for clients
like Chrome or Android,
and JPG for all others.
In addition, we had to
remember that, on the client,
WebP does cost a little
bit more to decode.
So we wanted to see if the
benefits outweigh the cost.
This experiment displayed
an average savings
of over 20% of transferred
bytes and up to 10% improvement
in apge rendering
time, which translates
to a huge improvement in overall
user experience, not to mention
that, on the mobile clients,
like our Android application,
bandwidth savings were
particularly helpful,
as images are a significant
contributor to data usage,
even compared to video.
So we got a lot
of great feedback
from the users experiencing
a smoother and faster UI.
Based on this result,
we decided to start
encoding new thumbnails
in WebP along with JPG.
And as a result, WebP currently
contributes to over 10%
of all user image traffic,
saving terabytes of bandwidth
every day and are expected
to become as popular as JPG
in near future,
especially as we enable it
on our iOS client, TV, and
console clients, and allow
third parties to use it, too.
They're very happy
with WebP at YouTube,
and I encourage you to consider
it for your site, as well.
Check out the WebP homepage
to learn about the format
and how to get started.
Thank you.